the other day I came across an article
about the lost subway tunnels of Los
Angeles not from the new subways that
they're building but from the old days
when the Pacific Electric red cars were
applying the streets of LA County and I
knew about a couple of them but there
was one that I never heard of and this
article actually gave the addresses for
the buildings that are on top of or
right in front of the old exits it also
said that the boneventure hotel cut
right through the Foundation's cut
through the tunnel so that was enough
information for me to go on google maps
and plot to both entrances and the sort
of south and the north and then draw a
line and see where that tunnel was just
made me realize that if you were in the
places along that line in LA you could
kind of look down metaphorically and
realize that there was space underneath
you there was infrastructure buddy mine
here in the office Rob cap saw what I
was doing and he said that he knew about
the same kind of thing in San Francisco
he knew of one entrance to a tunnel II
didn't know what it was we did a little
bit going around we figured out it was
part of an old train line that service
Fisherman's Wharf use Google Street for
you to find the other insurance and drew
another line right under fort mason park
if you're in the community garden and
you dig down too deep plant the wrong
root vegetable I suppose he end up in a
tunnel so that made me start thinking
about underground cities in general
because I know that there are huge
cultures of urban spelunking in places
like Paris with its catacombs or New
York and forgotten sewer subway tunnels
and there's something romantic about
that I know that in the history of
humanity there's plenty of stories about
the underworld but to me there's
something really elegant about the idea
of building our own underworlds these
places that exist that we create but
that happened so long ago that we forget
about them and then remember them again
later that's happened in Chicago it's
happened in Las Vegas where people live
in the water tunnels that are there to
get the desert rain out of the city
before everybody floods out all of it
put me in mind of a story the scariest
thing that ever happened to me in a city
which I suppose I'm lucky because this
isn't super scary but when i was first
living in New York mid-90s sometime I
was crossing Houston at about first
street or avenue a somewhere in the east
village middle of the night headed to a
bar I suppose I looked to my left when I
was on the center median and saw a shape
coming toward me and realized that it
was a person
I couldn't doubles a man or woman person
was wearing some kind of big cloak
backlit by the oncoming traffic and and
I sort of stopped paralyzed because I
didn't know what this person was doing
and they were on the center median on
houston and then that person stopped
bent over and lifted up what I realized
was a great door a manhole cover
something that led underground and then
paused and then disappeared into it just
dropped right into the ground and the
great close behind him or her and I
found that terrifying but also exciting
because what it taught me in that moment
before I'd ever read anything about this
in New York was that there was a whole
city under my city that there was an
infrastructure down there that I didn't
know about that I was never going to see
and i found that weirdly comforting to
know that there were pieces of this
thing that humanity had created this
city all around me that were mysterious
that were hidden all of which is not to
say that all of us should be going out
trying to find those places because
potentially I suppose that's dangerous
or not right but i will say that i'm
glad they're there and watch your step